this
massive thing that happened between
january 27th and january 31st
2021 at the time we're filming this as
you know that was the game stop
explosion implosion you know wall street
bets on reddit
all those things that you can google and
search and see all the stories on it but
i'm going to go behind and just take a
look
at robinhood itself picking up where the
case study left off
in 2018 they were the darling
the darling that had dared to disrupt
the financial services industry to give
you and me
basic people the ability to open an
account and go trade stocks
great wonderful they had gotten venture
capital money they went along they had a
lot of
people that were starting to use the
platform and i finished that case study
with a cutoff date in 2018 when they
were looking to hire a cfo
that had the chops to take them to an
ipo
and at that time everybody thought
that's where they were going and i
thought there was great promise for them
let's pick up the story so here we are
in 2017 and 2018
and the orange line here is a number of
users like you and me that had accounts
that were using robinhood
they were on this trajectory here so
ignore all this and let's just look at
this spot right here
going from 1.3 billion valuation
that's a valuation that the investors
are investing money we're investing at
so if you'd put in 100 million dollars
here on 1.3 billion dollars you would
have had like 1
13 of the company so that was the
company valuation
it had gotten up to 5.6 billion as they
tripled from 2 to
six million in users now you can see if
you look at that
you project right back down here past
the biz doc logo
to my old board from two years ago you
can see
wow that was a damn nice trajectory that
they were on
so from that point right there they
don't go public but they keep cranking
along
so what happens well in 2019 they raised
323 million dollars in a series e
and the series of investments are
usually have a letter a b
c d e for each one you've been through
so series e is like the fifth major
round
they're off and running and they went
from 6 million to 10 million users with
a valuation of 7 billion
so they're on a trajectory this is a
serious company now
not even public and already worth seven
billion dollars
but you'll notice that it's worth that
on authentic
volume of real trades which were at that
point
already approaching 150 billion dollars
of transactions a year in other words
you add up the
stock transaction that was made and what
is the total value of all those
transactions
well they were eclipsing in 2019 already
150 billion dollars
stepping back 2018 at the time of the
last case study it was about 100 billion
and in 2017.50
so you could see the trade transactions
are following the valuation increase
which was following the number of users
it was all interrelated and they got a
real business here giving people like
you and me
an opportunity to get trades on wall
street and have a stock account
for zero dollars per trade which was the
disruptive point
and we'll get to who it was disrupting
in just a minute so
they go there and then you get to 2020
right before the fun starts
and they raised 200 million dollars 320
million dollars and 460 million dollars
that's right in 2020. so someone was
there constantly raising money
constantly talking to investors
a lot of investors are probably pounding
on the door saying let me into this
thing
i want a piece let me in because they
know it's going to have an ipo someday
probably and so they're
they're rocking and they're at 13
million users and they cross
10.2 billion dollars in valuations
so let's stop right here a second before
we get to boom boom and everything that
happened at the end of january 2021
as we stand here actually we stand here
in february 2021
with all of the aftermath on the ground
around us so
we step back and we look here we say was
everything all rosy well if you look at
this side of the chart it looks rosy
but there was something going on in here
to give a zero dollar trade there has to
find a way to pay it how do you pay for
the computers how do you pay for the
systems how do you run a business
well robinhood was charging for things
like add-ons having a savings account
loans things like that there were ways
to make money but if you take
zero dollars for trades the market has
to respond
so other companies have to go zero
dollar trades because they want the
business of middle america
if you're putting five thousand dollars
into a robin hood account
well somebody else like a swab or an
e-trade or a td american trade
they all want that money too they'll
take a five thousand dollar account for
you and charge little fees and charge
you for trades
they want your business especially
because it doesn't hardly cost them
anything because it's an online account
with all the security that you need
online but there's not like a broker
actually
working with you when you call in
customer service there's people there
but you're not assigned a broker with
all the higher costs
it's really moving it to online moving
it to low cost moving it to automated
moving it to no human touch
your mouse clicks you buy stock well you
when you pick it down to zero there's
still costs to be covered
how did robin hood get paid well one of
the things
that they got paid for was a thing
called
payment for overflow pfof
so when robinhood takes those trades
they're going to go to the stock market
and there's people that are doing the
trading on the stock market
this is called order flow hey i got a
million orders today
what do you pay me for those and there's
little slivers
of the actual stock transaction that's
in there that becomes the payment for
order flow
well guess what the payment for order
flow also can be tied to
do you want to send it to this
organization to make your trade on the
market
or that organization and what if robin
hood got
paid a little sliver from this guy
but they got two slivers from this girl
uh oh there's an incentive
to even know this is a little tiny bit
but it's bigger than this tinier bit
and they go that way well guess what
payment for order flow
is how robinhood was making money thanks
for watching the short clip if you like
that and like to see the whole episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here